ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
welt meine lieben volle davon geht es
direkt ab das sind zombies kommen wieder
nicht wir haben für heute wieder extrem
viel laufen
ich weiß aber das ist ja gut er aber
davon lebt das projekt sache numero uno
die wir direkt mal checken müssen sind
die schildkröten reihe hier sieht alles
noch relativ gleich aus hier sind noch
gar nicht geschlüpft und die auch da
wurde mir nämlich auch unten
mir wurde nämlich auch unten die
kommentare geschrieben dass diese
schildkröteneier wohl nur schlüpfen bei
nacht kommt er zu mir her schön sterben
nachdem ich im neckar war alter könnte
mir nichts mehr ein jahr guck mal du
scheiß ganzen jahr antun
wir sollten dieses neuen schmiede von
rechts mein gott oh mein gott
ich verliere einfach meine komplette
erfahrung nur wegen solcher tasche ja
nicht träumen nach von den haag guck mal
hier kommt er nicht hoch ist bisschen zu
knappen bisschen bisschen verliert ja
komm rein hereinspaziert kommt stimmt
gar nicht zunächst einmal setzen wir den
bambus hier noch mal so ein bisschen
drüber damit er sich so ein bisschen
weiter verbrechen das alles ein bisschen
schneller wächst in dann müssen wir nach
unten gehen und ganz ganz ganz viel
[Musik]
decke undicht wir müssen ganz viel stein
farmen geht auch wärme tut auch dort
aber jetzt mit slime bolz und damit
können wir klebrige pisten zu machen und
damit können wir wiederum coolen sachen
machen und die brauche ich eigentlich
gerade gar nicht für das heutige video
habe ich allen anderen clan meine lieben
freunde und zwar möchte ich
trommelwirbel einen aus seht ihr das hat
heute eine blutabgabe war ich sogar bin
für meinen plan mit dem bahnhof brauche
ich extrem viel stein deswegen befinde
ich mich gerade schon leider leider am
strip meinen ich finde das immer nie so
geil weil dies immer ein bisschen
spannender finde wirklich in der höhle
zu gehen und so was wie ärzte zum
beispiel wie diamanten die man ja hier
aufhört 12 auf der ich mich gerade
befinde
am ehesten findet in minecraft das finde
ich mal ein bisschen cooler wenn man die
normal entdeckt sage ich mal in einer
höhle und dann hingegen wolldecke und du
denkst
allerdings braucht er hat eine menge
cobblestone und deswegen bietet sich das
stück meinen hier gerade perfekt ans
meine spitzhacke schrott ich möchte ja
meine kleine insel mit der riesigen
festland insel wie kann fest an eine
insel sein luca ich möchte diese beiden
orte miteinander verbinden und dafür
hatte ich ja den riesigen plan einen
unterwasser tunnel zu bauen als ob so
schnell jetzt und ich bin auch gehörig
weit gekommen und habe gar keine
diamanten gefunden mein ursprünglicher
plan war es ja einen riesig langen
unterwasser tunnel zu bauen mit glas und
mit glas und das dann schienen
durchlaufen und wir können dadurch
fahren und gucken uns die korallenriffe
an und alles das
die langsamkeit
wie sie gut gelaufen
schnell schneller
du bist du geschützt
allerdings tribut
[Musik]
weg
das ist nicht wahr ok ich glaube es hat
nachgelassen
mein herz wieder rot und ich hab keinen
bock auf reden dann war das das komische
geräusche was ich vorhin unten gehört
habe ich doch das habe ich gar nicht
rein geschützen weil wahrscheinlich habe
ich ja ich kann überhaupt nicht mehr
reden ich glaub ich hab das geräusch was
ich vorhin noten in der höhle gehört
habe gar nicht rein geschnitten weil ich
habe kurze zeit danach
guckt euch das einfach an was war das
war dass ich bin diesem seltsamen
geräusche nicht auf die schliche
gekommen deswegen dachte ich mir mensch
einbildung ist ausbildung
ich weiß dass wir besuchern machen heute
geht nicht mal ausnahmsweise nach durch
allerdings geht dahin schon die sonne
auf der zieht es auch wirklich durch
märz dank du bist auch noch tot kann mal
ein bisschen gucken bei den sch
wir haben die nacht überlebt die sonne
geht nach vorne auf und diese
schildkröte haben nun auch schon risse
diese art lieben ich guck mal so sehen
die eigentlich relativ normal große aus
aber so die laufer zum wasser ein das
ist ja wahr hatten sie das ist ja hey
wer gewinnt ich 650 euro auf dem linken
macht
lauf
[Musik]
dr
die frage die ich mir jetzt allerdings
schneller ist
ich habe ja die schildkröten sich fahren
lassen damit ich diese horn schilde
bekomme um mir einen helm zu machen mit
dem ich unter wasser atmen kann aber wo
sind diese horn schildert dann habe ich
zwei minuten lang versuchte einen großen
baum neben meiner farm wachsen zu lassen
bis dann logischerweise das hier
passierte
[Musik]
es kann doch nicht sein dass sich
einfach nur für zwei minuten ein paar
bäume pflanzen in dem moment kommt wo
ich gebe dem baum jetzt noch einen
verdammten versuch groß zu werden
und sonst ein scheiß hast du gesagt du
bist seit folge nicht auf meiner seite
der funktioniert wieder alles
dann können wir das ja auch wieder zu
bauen den weg machen war sobald das hier
fertig ist ich kann auch mal ganz gut
und die sonne geht schon wieder ich bin
meiner stunde 14 und hat nicht einen
blog für meinen bahnhof gesetzt von
daher mache ich jetzt mal ganz ganz fix
und imap sich mir die ganzen sachen
zusammen suche die ich für mein bahnhof
bauen
[Musik]
und da wären wir auch meine lieben
freunde zunächst einmal muss ich hier
den sand ein bisschen abtragen denn
genau dort wo ich gerade stehe sehe ich
den bahnhof auf jeden fall denn und da
können sich vielleicht der ein oder
andere akribische aufmerksame zuschauer
von projekten sehen wir das projekt zu
erfolgen hat auf jeden fall befindet
sich ja hier unser haus und die insel zu
der wir wollen befindet sich dort ganz
hinten 349 blöcke von daher startet
genau hier mit ich von unserem haus die
bahnstrecke die losläuft von hier zack
da hinten hin
und nein sie wird nicht komplett unter
wasser durchlaufen weil ich werde es
niemals schaffen 1750 glasglocke fertig
zu kriegen stattdessen möchte ich den
großteil unserer bahnstrecke zur anderen
seite wirklich so aus bruchstein hier
über das wasser legen jedoch einen
kleinen teil da wo die korallenriffe
sind ich weiß nicht ob man die von hier
sehen kann
da so ein bisschen da soll auf jeden
fall einen glastunnel auf jeden fall
also ich möchte unseren tanz ein
bisschen treu bleiben allerdings nicht
komplett weil das ein bisschen
überambitioniert werden allerdings
konzentrieren wir uns jetzt erstmal auf
den kleinen bahnhof ich werde jetzt
nicht so ein standard bahnhof bauen wie
man den irgendwie aus bielefeld kennt
oder so bielefeld bei gewährter für den
hässlichsten bahnhof der welt und dann
hat man hier so eine kleine sitzbank
beziehungsweise wartebank das macht zwar
keinen sinn weil wir müssen ja auch
keine züge warten die züge bilden
einfach irgendwelche loren die daher
fahren dafür brauchen wir noch eine
menge gold denn diese loren sollen mit
antriebs schienen verschiedenen versehen
versuchte nur manchmal ganz kurz zu
zeigen wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe
und zwar beispielsweise sich hier dann
einem bruchstein zur seite eine redstone
fackel drauf und jeder antrieb china das
ist quasi eine ganz normale schiene
sowie die die ich hier läge 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 und dann hier bei jedem elften
blog
setzt sich quasi mannen bruchstein und
eine redstone fakten und dieser antrieb
china ist aus gold und sorgt dafür dass
immer wenn die lore dort drauf hat das
ding war eine rakete nur deutlich
langsamer also eher wie ein dreirad mit
drei kaputten reifen in richtung anderer
insel fährt mir spaß beiseite das ist
auf jeden fall ein ganz gutes
fortbewegungsmittel wir konzentrieren
uns hier allerdings weiter auf unseren
bahnhof das hier sind so ein bisschen
die stützpfeiler ich weiß es braucht man
bei minecraft nächsten deutsch heute
wieder hat geld vom ein ich weiß dass
man solche ganzen sachen in minecraft
nicht braucht und das wird doch völlig
ausreichen wenn ich hier einfach diese
bahnstrecke hinlegen würde allerdings
nicht so ein bisschen schneller
das brauchen wir so auch nicht aber ich
find das auch schöner wenn das dann hier
steht naja dann eben hier geht es dann
auf jeden fall weiter in die richtung
zack und das hier steht natürlich
selbstverständlich auch so stelzen denn
hier auf die seite da habe ich ihnen was
überlegt und geht die sonne schon wieder
warum über zwei stunden
hier sollen nämlich auch treppen hin und
hier vorne zack zack zack zack auch und
hier möchte ich dann auch ein bote
hinsetzen so dass wir dann von hier
beispielsweise wenn wir darüber wollen
mit dem boot fahren aber wenn wir zu der
insel der insel da ganz hinten wollen
dann können wir beispielsweise das kart
nehmen also unsere ece 3000 der besseren
für die zugverbindungen und in die
kommentare allerdings nimmt der ganze
apparat dann so seinen lauf hier vorne
packen wir diese stein ziegel noch mal
darauf und auf die stein ziegel kommen
nun glatte steinstufen ich wusste gleich
dass es sowas in minecraft so richtig
gibt und zwar bildet das ihr so ein
bisschen das doch dann sehr industriell
gehaltene dach von unserem bahnhof ich
gehe erst mal scharf ich hab kein bock
auf'n krise glatten steinstufen bilden
das dach von unserem bahnhof allerdings
kommt hier dann auch noch so ein kleines
ab dach drüber damit man nicht nass wird
wenn man auf seinen zug wartet das
brauche ich noch ein bisschen zu ende
die sache ist allerdings dass ich euch
erstmal zeigen möchte was hierhin kommt
denn da habe ich mir so laternen
überlegt damit ihr allerdings nicht
einfach so darunter hängen werden die
soße ein bisschen eingegrenzt auch von
so glatten steinstufen
und hier vorne und da könnten wir auch
etwas anders nehmen irgendwie kloster
oder so aus dem netter allerdings habe
ich das in meiner test welt ein bisschen
vorgearbeitet und das fand ich jetzt
nicht so schön also gerade besonders
wenn ich euch das hier gleich mal bei
nacht zeige seht ihr dass das so schon
deutlich geile aussieht und im bahnhof
deutlich mehr ähnelt zack die hier an
der ecke dass man nicht auch ein
bisschen schöner hier vorne muss ich
einmal um das laub rum und dann noch
hier die seite eben zu ende und hier
vorne auch noch zwei dran und dann
müssten wir auch eigentlich schon fertig
sei nicht mal kurz diesem sandton hier
vorne ab zack zack zack live-act 4000
und ein paar sekunden später also auf
meiner zeichnung hier auf dem zweiten
bildschirm sieht der bahnhof ticken
anders aus ich weiß nicht was ich da
anders gemacht habe allerdings ja es ist
unsere kleine bahn station immer der
liebe freunde ich finde es eigentlich
ganz schön einem ich habe auch ein paar
sachen geachtet dass die unter wasser
auf jeden fall von der statik er
hinkommt und funktioniert ich weiß das
macht keinen sinn in mein geschäft aber
generell wenn ihr euch das komplette
projekte anguckt macht auch überhaupt
keinen sinn dass ich gerade das hier
baue weil ich könnte auch einfach mit im
boot rüber fahren das war genauso
schnell und deutlich entspannter und
glaube ich bin schön also diese ganze
korallen welche unter wasser feiere ich
schon wirklich extrem und das werk sehr
sehr geil gewesen wenn wir diesen
glastunnel hier oben sichtbar gemacht
hätten
ich habe das allerdings wirklich mehr
atteste welt ausprobiert und der wäre
dann hier raus gekommen und jetzt sag
einmal durch und das geld wirklich nur
dieser teil geil gewesen der rest sieht
dann halt einfach so aus ist halt auch
nicht sogar zu dem was soll diese doofen
glas text du die ganze zeit dafür haben
wir allerdings eine schöne zugstrecke
und man kann das ziel der hinten noch
immer nicht sehen obwohl ich hier
wirklich schon einiges gebaut habe aber
ich glaube das sind ganz schöne da kann
man auf diesen fahrten von meiner insel
zu den anderen inseln
ein paar fragen beantworten und so habe
ich auf jeden fall bock drauf die
antriebs schienen et cetera ergänzen in
der nächsten folge da liegt noch eine
glatte stein stufe von mir und generell
hatte ich heute zwar eigentlich noch
vorne zweiten stall zu bauen
für ein paar schafe weil ich brauch
wolle weil ein perspektivisches ziel ist
auch noch ein leuchtturm das werde ich
in der heutigen folge allerdings nicht
mehr schaffen denn ich bin in der roda
teil schon wieder bei über zwei stunden
ich weiß nicht wo die zeit immerhin
verfliegt wenn ich dieses projekt
aufnehmen aber schaut euch das mal an
doch ich bin auf jeden fall happy und an
der stelle würde ich die heutige episode
minecraft mit luca dann auch beenden
meine lieben freunde wir können mal ganz
kurz auf unseren spiegeleiern hier vorne
schauen die hier sind immer nur noch so
ein bisschen gerutscht die auf jeden
fall schon deutlich mehr als noch zu
beginn der folge und das hier vorne ganz
leicht also wir beobachten das weiterhin
und dafür ist die nächste folge die
übermorgen am donnerstag um 20 auf einem
kanal online gehen wird perfekt gemacht
meine lieben freunde denn dort werde ich
meine lieben freunde mal wieder abend
eine
köhlen expedition machen
ich weiß dass ich die hälfte der
zuschauer gerade denkt geil und die
andere hälfte verdammt das lief letztes
mal alles andere als gut weil da bin ich
am pausenlosen band gestorben weil wir
brauchen wir ein paar diamanten wir
brauchen ein bisschen mehr redstone für
die red storm fackeln wir brauchen auch
generell mehr eisen und 2000 sofort also
ich suche mir der nächsten folge nur
neue höhle vielleicht auch unsere
anderen inseln schneidet auf jeden fall
wieder reinlassen daumen hoch und dem
video das euch gefallen hat abonniert
main kanal weil es noch kein teil der
doku seid und wir sehen uns übermorgen
wieder
[Musik]